you've written this book the book of
gutsy women right now you wrote this
with my daughter yeah we did
I'm gonna go down this list of some
people I think you got right but by the
way like I say these are the Academy
Awards yeah voted on by you and your
daughter that's the best women that you
could find examples of great guts
literally the book could have been like
a thousand pages long right but you both
had to agree on yes choice and we wrote
over 200 Robin and then we had to cut it
in half it was it was a challenging
process before I get that I got to ask
you one question that's always I bring
this up all the time my father put this
thought in my head
he used to say to me if the American
public could see Camp David there would
be a revolution in this country that in
other words our presidents are being
treated like kings my father says that a
great president would get rid of Camp
David this is my father
what is campaign but David is truly a
camp first of all it's a military base
right okay and it is rustic it is not
like a like it's not a pal no it's not a
palace why won't they show it to us well
there happened I you know there there
are pictures there's lots of pictures
online
of you know when President Carter had
meetings there and just the most recent
you know President Obama and apparently
Trump is going to have the g7 there
Obama had the g7 he can't have it in his
hotel can't have it at his hotel so it's
very rustic there's nothing special no
not at all and I mean there's my
father's wrong he was wrong yes yeah but
because but I bet in his time there were
very many pictures that's true yeah yeah
I know my father's got a hang-up with
that I'm talking about the book now just
and believe me I would like to get
awards from you from like I'd like to
know who your favorite Congress person
was I was gonna say I bet it's uh when
Lyndon Johnson was a congressman because
orbit Tip O'Neill because those guys
could bring together Republicans and the
we've got a lead Lowenstein was enough
oh he was a good guy wasn't he a good
guy yeah he's a good guy and he got
assassinated nobody makes a big deal
about that
you know there have been some really
tragic stories like that janitors of
Congress you know it's scary yeah yeah
it is well that's why I say becoming
first lady and then becoming a senator
and then running for president and
they're still screaming lock her up and
I know I know I think I'd be very scared
well you know look you can't be scared
you can't you just can't you can't let
that but you have Secret Service yes I
do and and you're a big difference
because as a as a former president
former first lady we have it how do you
live your life though if you're under
the constant gaze now since you were
first lady you know Howard you just have
to live your life I mean really you just
have to get do anything normal you don't
go to a supermarket I do you do but
you've got two dudes guys hanging there
they build the wait a little
I would love to see what goes on do you
and Bill ever say yeah why go out
tonight it's just gonna be too much of a
scene it's too much let's just stay home
well we probably have done that in the
last 25 years that's true
right but most of the time you know we
say let's go to movies we go to the
movies let's go out to dinner we go out
these guys ship behind you yeah I don't
mind that
Yeah right next to you behind us yeah it
works believe me at work but it probably
is a good thing for you Howard because
they don't let people sit next to them
Oh first of all I would love I would
love to have a full Secret Service team
I get a pickup I don't want to meet
anybody
you and bill you can hire some guys to
go around with you know things in their
ears yeah I went to the movies I went to
see the the mr. Rogers movie yeah I had
a guy sent by me really yeah well but
you know part of it I did my Secretary
of say my president we did the cone of
silence here look when you're as
well-known and as recognizable as you
are and as I am yeah you just have to
figure that it's going to happen so like
when we go to the theater you know we
sit on the aisle because we know people
are going to come up and that way you
know we can get the selfie we can stand
up and shake hands so bothering our
selfies the worst thing that ever
happened to a politician I mean come on
I'll tell you what you don't always want
to take a no you don't just want to and
you know I mean obviously sometimes you
wish you hadn't but right it is what
here's what I miss about it
so even when I ran in o8 for president
certainly when I ran for the Senate and
all of Bill's campaigns you know you
would do an event and then you would go
do what's called the rope line you know
where the audience was and you'd shake
hands and in that interaction people
would say something to you they might
say please keep fighting for healthcare
I have a child with a disability or they
might say here's my letter I'm a vet and
I can't get good care me you would have
a real human interaction okay by 2016
let's take a selfie let's take a self
that's all it's about and you would you
would not learn anything about what was
going on in that person's life when I've
missed that when you got criticized for
word
maybe not going to every state and
shaking every hand like everyone was
playing Monday Morning Quarterback
oh it's Hillary laws for this reason she
lost for that reason this is net and you
know who knows I'm sure you did your old
Monday morning yeah I wrote a whole book
about it I know did you did you feel
like maybe if you had gone to some diner
somewhere and you know I don't know in
the middle of vote nowhere and it shook
somebody's hand it would have made a
difference you never know that I mean
first I did I did go to a lot of the
places maybe not write that but I did
but I think that this election turned on
other factors
I think you know look Russians and
WikiLeaks really did a job on me both in
terms of the way they weaponized
information and then the way that they
and they're gonna do it again they're
doing it again when they're doing it to
whoever else is gonna be up there and I
think you know the call me letter ten
days before the election killed me
and that was awful it was unbelievably
awful how'd he get over that pain of
Comey doing that to you it was so
shocking and I thought that I had made
it through but then I went back and and
for my book what happened I looked at a
lot of polling like for example I can't
believe you went back and looked I did
because I wanted to figure it out
because look you know if you if you do
something you throw yourself into it for
two years and it doesn't work out the
way you think it will and the way that
everybody also believed it would what
went on what happened so there was all
kinds of stuff and I and I've told this
to everybody running who I've talked to
and I've talked to most not all I said
look you can't remain in the current
crockery crop you could run the best
campaign and you can get the nomination
but here are four things you got to
watch out for number one voter
suppression the other side wants to
shrink the electorate they don't want
everybody to vote they want to try to
cut out you know you're losing young
people and whatever okay number two if
you haven't had your personal email
stolen it will be but I bet it already
has been its bank somewhere and they
will use it to try to paint a picture of
you that is totally untrue and they
could have our personal email stolen and
look good well very few but even if it's
nothing
insidious illegal and that's what I mean
you can twist anything and and then
thirdly they're gonna lie about you
repetitively on social media
particularly Facebook and they're going
to target it at people who are
susceptible to that and you read this
stuff and you have to sit there every
times I do I just ignore it or do I take
it on you know here I'll tell you so
there was a study done after my election
by Ohio State University and they went
and found people that said they had
voted for Obama in 2012 and voted for
Trump in 2016 and they really dug in and
said okay why why why and it was all
about what they saw on Facebook because
over 50% of Americans get their news
from Facebook that's crazy that crazy
yeah now that doesn't mean that the New
York Times now is a bunch of liars
there's greatest newspaper ever and and
they feed into it because they won't you
know they won't draw lines but so what
happens with the you know the whole
thing about what do we believe and what
do we not believe all the rest his
people now are genuinely confused so
these researchers said okay well what
did you believe what changed your mind
number one she was dying and they got
they got news feeds from places like
Macedonia or st. Petersburg you know the
Russians were really good at this where
they had somebody looking like an
American with American accented English
who would say yet another expert has
said that she has Parkinson's she won't
live out her term anyway so second that
I had somehow gotten arms to Isis
totally made-up I mean beyond absurd
third that Pope Francis had endorsed
Trump they got it out they're totally
into people's Facebook feeds who only
get news from Facebook or maybe get it
supplemented by Fox but right you know
so we're living in these very you know
it's a weird time it's very 1984 it's
really hard did you did you have your
first hundred days kind of planned in
your head yes here's my perception of
the president's yeah yeah you get one
shot you get that first hundred days
right you got a pic really one thing
you're passionate about you're not gonna
get fifty things through you're not
gonna get two things through you're
probably gonna get one major push and
you would have had a tough time because
you would had a Republican Congress and
Senate right what was the one thing you
knew in the back of your mind you were
gonna get done if by any way possible
well taking on at that point I was gonna
have to try to do more than one thing
because we had to we had to shore up and
save healthcare and try to get it on a
much firmer footing and expanded we had
to figure out what we're gonna do about
immigration which is tearing this
country apart and it is the biggest
cudgel that is used against people and
their and their the Senate passed a
bipartisan bill in 2013 and the house
wouldn't bring it up because they'd
rather have a political issue than solve
a problem
that's where we are so you would have
pushed on that I would have pushed on
that yeah and I would have gotten people
lined up as quickly as possible to get
confirmed as judges do you think yeah I
know do you think that Trump is
responsible for the good economy right
now or do you think it was an Obama
thing because as you mentioned when
Obama came into office it was a mess I'm
talking about the economy right we saw a
constant uptick in the economy all
through the Obama years maybe not as
fast as people would like but what the
heck right going up and up and up and up
great the guy who comes into after Obama
isn't necessarily in one day gonna fix
the economy right he's benefiting from
whoever his predecessor was would that
be your assessment or should Trump take
a bow and say hey this is am i doing
look I think that the economy is largely
operating because of what Obama did and
it was as you remember really hard and
it helped to spark the Tea Party because
he made some tough decisions that you
know saving industries that nobody
thought should be saved but for the good
of the economy had to be saved so I give
the bulk of the credit still to Obama
what I here's what I worry about I think
the economy is a kind of a right now an
even keel but I do see some problems
sort of forming underneath
I think these trade battles that he's
picked that he has been you know just
bellicose about our short term wins but
medium and long term losses I think the
tax cut the huge tax cut it was a boon
for corporations and for the very
wealthy but it didn't bring about the
kind of investments that you need to
build the economy for everybody so now
you've got people who could not put
together $400 in an emergency Howard
yeah that's bad and and car payments are
way behind schedule people are late on
car payments credit card debt is going
back up again because even though we
have a lot of people working it's not as
many people as a percentage of
population as it was when Bill was there
and so we've got some slack in the
economy so look I'm I'm glad I mean I'm
not one of these people who
in hopes for a collapsed economy that's
not that's too much pain for people I
would never do that but I do worry that
we're not on a solid trajectory when you
were standing in the I guess they called
the Situation Room behind Obama they're
about to kill bin Laden right
you knew that was a huge moment right
huge were you thinking again this could
have been my presidency no really no
were you glad in a way it wasn't because
that's a that's a heavy thing when you
see these guys going in well I
I recommend it you know there was a
split among his advisors and I was one I
was in the small group that said go
after him and and go ahead and do it
with a Navy SEAL team and you watched
the whole operation go again are you
allowed to go home and tell your husband
that this has happened you know you're
not no and I know I once it happened and
the president announced it you know I
mean before the president was it so
here's a funny story so the raid takes
place yeah and then we each had calls to
make I had calls to certain leaders and
and members of the Senate Obama was
calling all the former presidents
so he gets bill on the phone he goes
well you know Hillary's probably told
you this but bill said told me what
don't know I didn't tell anything I mean
it was like it was one of the most
intense public experiences I've ever had
and here was in my view the right way to
make a presidential decision so there
was a small group of us and we were we
were meeting we met numerous times we
looked at all the different angles we
looked at all of the intelligence to
figure out was this real or not and that
was not an easy decision
and then the president would come in and
meet and and we would go through it with
him and then the final day of our last
meeting he went around the table and he
asked everybody to tell him what they
thought was Biden there
iDEN was there What did he say good
don't do it right iDEN said don't do it
a gate said don't do it I mean you know
because the risks were enormous right
you were gonna fly into Pakistani
airspace land in a place called Abad
Abad which happened to be where the
pakistani military academy is like West
Point and
launched an assault to take out the you
know the most horrific terrorist in our
history so you don't fault by them for
saying no I know I don't know here's my
point was in this room this was
presidential decision-making because we
all said what we thought but he had to
make the decision and he said I'm gonna
think about it I'm gonna sleep on it and
you know I made my case as to why we
should do it I mean I I felt a special
responsibility having been in New York
nobody afterwards and seeing all that
were you like on why does he make up his
mind because why should he sleep on it
let's get in there no I admired that you
did yes I don't not like impulsive
decision makers right because and he
also listens to other teens any probes
and why do you believe that and why
don't you believe that you watch bin
Laden die
no we the we the video ended when the
seals got into the complex into the
buildings because of a technical reason
or because you didn't want it didn't I
think both I think both because you know
you're they had you know night-vision on
and the cameras were on but it would
have been grainy and not very good and
why have that remember I agreed with the
President as well not to release
pictures yeah so when when here's here's
a story that I like to tell because most
people don't know it you know you know
about you know you know about the seals
going in you may know that one of the
helicopters crashed that's right and
luckily we had tried to think of every
possible scenario so there had been
another helicopter positioned nearby to
come in to take out the seals but the
one that had crashed was a new stealth
helicopter it had to be blown up so that
the technology wouldn't fall into the
wrong hands so they killed bin Laden
they have to take his body out because
we have to do the DNA back when they get
to Afghanistan so they have to blow up
this helicopter those Navy SEALs after
having shot their way into that killed
the Kuwaiti courier killed his brother
killed one of you know bin Laden's adult
sons wounded one of the women who was
after them they took the women and
children out and they took them to the
other side of this big compound as far
away from the helicopter
explosion as they could so they wouldn't
be injured now that's when I think about
the American military that's who I think
about and I am sick to my stomach about
what Trump did hardening hardening three
men who had been tests they test were
testified against by their own men
because of the way they behaved what
else death well I don't know what it is
it's his it's his perverse understanding
of courage and and war in other words
there are rules there are there have to
be rules that's why I was so proud to
tell that story
what other military would you have that
right well you know often people are
waking up we're monitoring all the
chatter people are waking up they're
climbing to their roofs they're only a
mile away from this military academy and
our guys take the time to move this
family around first of all they didn't
kill them and then they brought him to
safety that's that's the American
military that that I know moves me it
moves me when you describe this it
brings tears to my eyes because what a
great what a great bunch of guys honor
that is honor and so you can't undermine
that military experience and and and the
Commandant and that level of quality of
service exactly did you do you I dare to
think listen I'm just an ordinary Schmo
you've been on the inside this stuff you
know that goes on I'm talking about CIA
FBI everything in other words should we
be in a panic is the world out there
even 50 times more dangerous than we
even understand have we been saved and
don't even know it
Oh often over and over and you know I
know that over and over and am I saved
you mean foiled plots to blow stuff up
and foiled plots turning you know spies
our way to all of a sudden we know more
and therefore we can preempt things plan
for things because people that there are
brilliantly devious and they have plots
that are incredibly sophisticated right
yeah and and they are constantly working
against us yeah I mean that's what
drives me crazy about the
Republicans today trying to defend the
indefensible with Trump's conduct and
defend the Russians I mean I said across
tables I sat in chairs next to Vladimir
Putin he is not our friend he's a
scumbag he's an adversary and he wants
to bring us down and you know what
they're smart about they could never
take us down militarily never they can't
take us down economically they've got a
you know small economy compared to ours
but they can divide us and they're doing
and they're doing it every single one
and for whatever reason and we won't
speculate about it for whatever reason
you know Trump is is in that camp with
them I don't know whether it's his ego
is narcissism I don't I don't pretend to
know but we see it we don't have to
psychoanalyze him to know that he is an
admirer of dictators and in particular
Putin but what bothers me are these
Republican senators they have not only
sacrificed their independent judgment
lost their mind they have they have
given up any any sense of patriotism in
my view do you this is a silly question
but do you know what's going on at that
area 51 I don't believe you know what
I'll tell you if I'd been president I
would have wanted to figure out how to
visit I know I would have wanted to take
me with air with you you know maybe
broadcast you could interview the aliens
does it upset you that that even your
fellow Democrats like when someone like
you said something today I never rule
out running again or something like that
fine okay yeah
they're angry they don't want you to run
again they got you know everyone's
pissed off and even your even your
allies are pissed some are just did you
just want to just lay in bed and say
[ __ ] this I'm getting out I mean I am
gonna go into full seclusion and they're
never gonna hear from me again no first
of all that would only delight my
adversaries so I would never do that
but secondly I have this unique
perspective some of which we've been
talking about yeah I have a unique
perspective I have a particular
understanding of the Russian threat and
it's not gonna only be Russia I mean so
you must be laying awake I do I worry a
lot you know how soon anagen czar I
worry I worry a lot you've negotiated
with them you've seen Secret
Intelligence and you know that you know
there's these guys who phoned from
Nigeria who phone your home and somehow
finagle six grand a day
am i doing that you're brilliant yeah
yeah I can only imagine what's going on
with Vladimir Putin sits there and plans
against the United States well but you
know you can read that the indictments
against the Russians and I you know a
lot of people didn't pay attention to it
but it's very informative and scary do
you mean the mullah report yeah the
indictments ok the report itself I think
is also worth reading but if you read
the indictments you know basically they
were like hey let's do everything we can
to elect Donald Trump I mean that's
those are quotes taken space no words
that taken and else's at Bernie Sanders
but you know that's another Bernie
Sanders what do we hate Bernie Sanders
no I don't hate anybody Bernie could
have endorsed you quicker he heard me
there's no doubt about it hurt me but
going back to the indictments cuz that's
what's really haven't spoken to burning
about that no no you can talk to him I
don't talk to him I mean we did you when
he finally endorsed me and all that what
you're upset with them now disappointed
disappointed okay
so and I hope he doesn't do it again to
whoever gets the nomination right once
is enough
we got we have to end what you know and
you know people could speculate and and
have some good reason to speculate about
how bad it might be with Trump in the
White House now we know there's no
guesswork we know and and we know that
given his personality and his his rage
against anyone who questions him lord
knows what he might try to do so it's
time to retire him but if you look at
that indictment I mean and 60 minutes
actually had a really good show on this
the other night where they took the what
they called the soldier hackers the
Russians who were doing it and they
pieced it all together so that you know
somebody watched in 60 minutes could
have an
standing of how the orders came from the
Kremlin they went to military
intelligence these guys were recruited
they pretended to be Americans they sow
discord they made all kinds of you know
phony news to try to influence people
and people who say all that didn't
influence you just mentioned the
Nigerian guys call yeah somebody gives
him six thousand dollars it's going
advertising spends many billions of
dollars to persuade you to do things of
course it had an impact on a
considerable number of his character
Rowan's Facebook are you post what a
disappointment yeah yeah what you know
for him to say uh you know we're not
going to take down you know fake ads you
know total lies basically which is what
Trump was running now on Facebook
against Biden is such an abdication
responsibility and I I don't understand
what's going through his head I've heard
him try to explain it he doesn't do a
very good job of it should be regulated
listen by radio my whole life it's
regulated I can't go on and slander you
I didn't get away with it no I know it
because at the beginning I think people
thought it would just be a pass through
but that's not what it turned out to be
the algorithms are determining so much
of what you actually freaky it is could
you support Bloomberg I'll support over
the Democratic nominee is I don't know
who that's good but why not be an
advocate from one person let's I mean I
know them I know them all I don't I
don't wanna get I don't want to get in
the middle no I don't want to get in the
middle it's up to the voters to decide
I think Bloomberg would be a good
president but I don't know if he can win
I have no idea we're gonna find out cuz
you know he's gonna he's not gonna
compete in the early contests I guess
but he's gonna compete on but I think
Biden to Budaj edge interesting right
he's very interesting very smart smart
guy when this guy speaks he makes sense
mm-hmm but your husband that doesn't
matter but your Steve but your husband
wish he had a way of talking explain or
in chief people forget that in October
of 2012 Mitt Romney was ahead yes right
and you know Bill was out there
campaigning for President Obama bill
spoke at his convention
because we all know what's at stake I
mean and and and Mitt Romney is a decent
man you know he's somebody who I think
is an honorable person and I may not
agree with them obviously so now that we
can see how one person with so much
power can have such a dramatic and in
damaging effect we got to all get behind
whoever gets the nomination